So one thing I knew we really wanted to do after the 101 course
is have a course on building web applications.
The cool thing about web application is instead of
just writing a program that you can use,
you can write a program that you can put on the web,
and then everyone on the world can also use it.
I wanted to find someone to teach the course who really
knows a lot about building web applications and I'm delighted that
we found Steve Huffman to be that. So, Steve, tell us
what the course is going to be about.
[Steve] Ok, so I started reddit.com as lead engineer about seven years ago
and more recently I started hipmunk.com a new travel site.
This course is basically going to cover the things I wish I had known
starting those websites.
Seven years ago getting into this business I had no idea what I was doing
and I learned most of what I know now through trial and error
and many lessons learned the hard way.
We're going to start with the internet and browsers and how they work.
We'll do form validation, databases, APIs to integrate with other websites
and we'll touch up some scaling issues as well.
So by the time you're done you'll have a blog that's online for you to use.
It will support multiple accounts and multiple blogs.
[David] Well, that sounds really cool. The class is going to start on April 16th.
[Steve] We'll see you there!
CS253: Web application engineering. Taught by Steve Huffman